[Music]
foreign welcome to the pretty intense
podcast thank you so much for coming
you're in for a treat today with
Professor David Buss he is a professor
of psychology at the University of Texas
he is the world's leading expert on
strategies in mating and an author with
several books his latest being when men
behave badly so I'm really fascinated
with why people choose certain people
what the psychology of cheating is the
psychology of sex The Mating hierarchies
they call it mate value women sort of
date lateral and up with the status and
success and men tend to date lateral and
down you know because I'm in this unique
position being a woman but yet being
successful yeah of course I'm very
curious so today was a conversation
about that we talked a lot about sex a
lot about why Partners want to have sex
the kind of Partners they choose why
they want to have sex cheating and why
people cheat in relationships Partners
choosing Partners we talked about
marriage later in the episode about if
that's sort of an institution that'll
stick around or not super interesting
stuff so enjoy this conversation please
hit the Subscribe button deeply
appreciate that and let me know what you
think in the comments and just thanks
for coming by
today's pretty intense partner is
athletic greens I take ag1 by athletic
greens literally every day covering my
nutritional basis for the day couldn't
be any easier which is why I trust
athletic greens just a mix of one scoop
of ag1 with water first thing in the
morning done I also like that it costs
less than three dollars a day pretty
good if you ask me it's a really
effective daily habit with the highest
quality sourced ingredients win-win if a
comprehensive solution is what you need
from your supplement routine then
athletic greens is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase go to athleticgreens.com pretty
intense that's athleticgreens.com pretty
intense check it out thank you very much
for doing this I have like such a
burning passion for psychology and like
what makes people like they are and
patterns and how to break them and
um why we are like we are and you know
definitely one of my super areas of
Fascination within that realm has been
around
um like
mate value and like why why genders
choose the people they choose and what
makes it hard because you know like for
me I know that like being smart and
being successful and various different
things make make my dating pool really
small because guys usually don't like to
have someone more successful than them
perhaps intelligent various different
things so like I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
eternally fascinated by this topic so
um so thank you for making the time to
um appease my
burning interests oh my hey my pleasure
um it's delightful to be talking to you
um and um I share that burning passion
for this topic I mean I've devoted my
life to studying human mating strategies
and right now I'm actually wrestling
with exactly the issues that you raised
under the the guys under the title of
the The Mating crisis and I'm currently
writing a book now with Chris Williamson
on that very topic because oh my God so
we we indeed have well made in crises
but one of the ones the one of the first
ones that I actually wrote about which
is an essay that I wrote uh seven years
ago was precisely the issue that you
identified with that that
increasingly there are women who are uh
attractive successful uh professionally
accomplished uh and their uh uh
shrinking pools of men who meet women's
standards so women generally uh in my
research and others don't like to settle
for guys who are they want guys who are
at least if not more successful than
they are uh and um and this is and this
is a problem whereas guys are are more
willing to settle for a less you know
um successful less financially uh
solvent uh lower in status Etc in part
because of the you know evolve mate
preferences that that have men men don't
places higher priority on those
attributes and the they do place a
higher priority compared to women on
physical attractiveness and physical
appearance and of course women also
place a high value on physical
appearance but just not as high as as
men do and so what it's doing is it's
actually creating two
different mating crises one a mating
crisis in mind you know accomplished
successful women but then also at the
other end you have the the in cells the
involuntarily celibate man A large group
of sexless men who are just simply a
lower inmate value in women's eyes and
so can't find a mate can't find a sex
partner can't find romance can't find a
long-term relationship it's growing and
that's getting worse right now correct
it is
um it's getting considerably worse
so that you have a an astonishing number
of young men who are virgins at age 30.
you know and you know and I think there
are uh you know multiple causes of that
we get into this the details of this but
I think they're a combination of things
like one is they're spending all their
time behind computer screens uh playing
video games
um on social media and looking at porn
um and so
um and so they are to my astonishment
they're not you know the stereotypes
these guys are living in their mom's
basement you know right they're not not
getting onto the real world they're not
um setting goals for themselves they're
not getting ahead
um and so they're not they're not
performing uh the the what historically
has been what men do
um is um you know strive in the
workplace and then ancestrally it would
have been being uh ambitious and
industrious and uh intelligent in in the
domain of hunting you know acquiring
resources consistently for themselves
for their mate for the children for
their families uh which causes them to
rise in status uh and then in the modern
environment you know getting ahead in
the workplace High status
and
qualities that lead to success are
highly valued by women so women value
guys and one of the biggest complaints I
get from women is like this guy he has
no goals he has no drive he doesn't know
what he wants to do with his life you
know he's not getting ahead
and so you fast forward you know you do
that in a few years you fast forward to
age 40 and there's these guys who
um you know are still living in their
mom's basement so against stereotype but
a bunch of Truth to that stereotype so
is there
is it is it is it that the
attractiveness from a male and female
perspective has not changed but the
reality of what a man and a woman is
experiencing and being right now is yes
yeah I think that summarizes it very
accurately
um
you know uh you could say like like for
example let's take
um
a financial stability or economic
solvency or a decent Financial prospects
this is something that women have valued
throughout human history
um and you might think well in the
nowadays with successful women who are
earning their own income and being
financially successful they don't quote
need a guy right right on the table
right they still want a guy they still
don't want to settle for a guy who's
lower than
um they are on these dimensions and so
the way that I think about it is our
evolved mate preferences continue to
operate in the modern world in women
over the last 10 20 years of
um gotten ahead gotten the head gotten
and and are surpassing the men on many
of these Dimensions so so even like in
the in the youngest age brackets let's
say
um uh 18 to 30. uh women are now out
earning men uh in the United States and
and in many Western countries and even
in Japan and South Korea and they're
also intellectually outperforming them
too when it comes to school as well so
there's been quite a few shifts yeah uh
educationally it's been astonishing and
this is It's really surprised me because
these are dramatic cultural uh shifts
that occurred within our lifetimes you
know in a relatively short period of
time and so I mean when I was an
undergraduate at University
um I think there was a preponderance of
men I don't know exactly what the stats
were but there was no um no one talks
about a surplus of women but now for
example at my university University of
Texas at Austin there's a 54 women and
undergraduates and 46 men you go up to
Texas Christian University uh up near
Dallas it's 60 women 40 men and every
year it gets a little bit more
imbalanced
um and and then there's the interesting
issue of why that's happening well I
think that also is mostly determined so
one is that on the educational front one
of the best predictors of
uh success is high conscientiousness the
personality variable of high
conscientious the people who are
reliable diligent
um attentive details uh set goals
um meet their goals uh and women are
higher than men on this sort of all the
way up and you want that with the fact
that men are and these aren't
intelligence differences as much as
personality differences are more likely
to be
um um on the Spectrum on the autism
spectrum so and what that means is that
so in like grades K through 12
um men have more difficulty sitting
still they have more difficulty
concentrating you know they want to be
out
doing
what men historically did
you know you'll get a deer okay
fighting they're learning hunting skills
they're doing they're Outdoors doing
physical stuff they're not used to
sitting still in school for six to eight
hours
um and so you know you know on the one
hand women being more conscientious and
then on the other men being high on this
uh Dimension the Spectrum disorders but
even short of the disordered end of the
spectrum you get many just more
distractible you know and they're less
able to
um sit still and concentrate on one task
at those at this early ages then you
fast forward to college applications
well
um women exceed men on quality of
getting in to a good college but you
said this is this has shifted so why if
this is a pattern within men that
they're you know wanting to be up and
about moving around and less sort of
focused in women or more why is it now
that women are doing performing better
in school versus men when this pattern
essentially hasn't changed yeah well I
think there it's a great question and
and there are a couple reasons for that
okay one is that I think that the
opportunities for women have basically
just opened up so it used to be expected
that um women would get married at a
very young age get pregnant
uh have kids and then of course that
takes you out of the um the workforce
and the educational system typically
right
um and so now though you you have uh
equal opportunity combined with
um a larger segment of the population
who are going to college and
universities so it used to be you know I
don't know I mean go back far enough you
know three and five percent then eight
percent because women were pregnant and
having children they weren't going to
college they were literally having kids
at 22. yes yeah
whatever it was it's many in high school
and then you have also other things like
um you know Advent of the pill and
reliable contraception meaning that you
know I mean young people have sex that's
what they do
um and um without reliable birth control
then you have a higher pregnancy rate uh
so you add the pills so that women can
control
you know reproduction the timing of the
reproduction
um and then that adds to it as well so
they say no I'm not I want to devote
time to my career first you know and
then worry about mating uh and getting
married and
even within college is something it's a
stereotype but it used to be so the only
reason women go to college is to get
their Mrs that used to be the the joke
yeah they're they find find a husband
who's going to be uh a doctor or a
lawyer and they get married and settle
down
um and that and that there was some
truth that's kind of a cliche but
there's some truth to that
uh and so now with the uh men and women
expected to be sort of have equal
opportunities to do these things some of
the natural proclivities
of the Sexes and the sex of differences
are are showing up in ways that they
they weren't earlier when a smaller
segment of the populations is um going
to college and universities
so and and the other thing that kind of
adds to that the back to the mating
crisis for women so women are now
getting more uh college degrees more
master's degrees more phds and then more
professional degrees so this is also
occurring with um
medicine uh more MDS more law degrees
uh and that takes time and so then women
are older before they're in a um
position where they say okay now I'm
ready to settle down and made
but then you have this pool of men
uh the subset of men who are
um ambitious and get ahead and have good
jobs and a reliable income
uh they are typically marrying women who
are younger than they yep it's like a
whole catch problem it's like I've
thought about this a lot because of my
position I'm 41. I I did used to be
married a long long long time ago but
I'm basically single and so
um you know it's challenging out there
and I kind of Wonder because men I feel
like seem to not want to settle down for
much longer like a woman like myself
like a man
that's about my age might be trying to
find a
six to 30 year old woman because now
he's ready to commit but that's the age
that they're they're looking for to have
children with right like because they're
and so like there's this gap for someone
like me let's say where I'm a little
past that I'm like right at the end of
the reproductive years of like deciding
to do that or not but the only kind of
guy that you're gonna get like not the
only kind of guy but more predictably
you're probably going to find someone a
little bit older and and the younger guy
is not available because they've all of
a sudden now decided oh well now I'll
settle down it just seems like you kind
of there's like a Miss with sort of
goals in life yeah yeah absolutely so
well so how do you
um deal with that so so I I'm sure so in
your case you're you're attractive
you're successful you're intelligent you
have a lot going for you and I'm sure
there are many many many men who would
give their right arm to be with you but
it's a matter of this says a lot coming
from someone who studies why people
choose people well it's just I it's
accurate I think and but there's but but
then for you they're given that you have
made preferences for you don't want to
settle for the guy who's
um you know on the janitorial staff of
you know buildings or what how do you
deal with that
I guess I'm willing to overlook usually
the financial side of things but the
problem is then
is it's actually
far more of a problem for them than it
is for me yeah like someone that doesn't
as financially successful or as
successful as me they actually have the
bigger problem than I do even though
mate value would say that I want a man
that is more successful has a higher
status
it's actually them that has a problem
because they're triggered by me uh
here's why or here's my speculation
thank you so why
um is that
statistically that is going to create a
make value discrepancy right so even
though you're you're fine you know with
I'm sure you wouldn't be fine if he's
like has minimum wage uh but um you know
I'm sure so let's say you would you're
willing to relax you know he doesn't
have to be as financially well off as
you are right
um that's fine but that what that means
is that um uh that he's going to be
intimidated by you still because
statistically there's a higher
probability uh of you finding someone
better and and trading up and trading
him out because this is one of the
things that that has been remarkable is
that
um with successful women they no longer
put up with a bad relationship or a bad
marriage they're they're because they
can they can just get out you know
whereas women in the past and some women
today still are not in that financial
position to do that and so there's a
little more stuck yeah they're stuck in
these bad relationships or bad marriages
and they can't get out but hey if you if
you if you're financially independent
you're not you can and and then you know
and so and there's also and not saying
that this applies to you uh but
statistically there's also a higher
probability of infidelity
by the higher mate value person in
general so if the man happens to be
higher and make value he's going to be
like the
probabilistically you know so obviously
not in all cases most people don't have
affairs uh but
something like a third do uh and um and
it's the higher mate value person who
typically is more likely to have an
affair and is more likely to leave the
relationship
uh and so so he's so yeah so if he this
um let me put it in start terms it's
lower mate value guy
um feels very lucky to get involved with
you but also very insecure uh because
realistically there's a higher
probability you might trade them out
does it doesn't lead to a man going and
sort of conquering someone underneath
them so they can feel important and like
um of a higher value you're saying that
a woman is still going to be the one
that's more likely to cheat in an
imbalanced mate value relationship
because whoever's more successful yeah
whoever the more successful one is
because I can see where there could be a
spot for especially for the um the the
woman being of higher higher success and
Status being doing that okay but the man
wanting to feel pout empowered and
Powerful Again by Me by going and uh
cheating with someone of a lower value
so they can achieve that feeling that
um through history has been their
pattern yeah yeah no I think that that
captures it quite well and I mean this
gets to an interesting sex difference in
motivations for infidelity yeah let's
let's talk about that uh so yeah so well
so
why men cheat
mostly theater we're talking about on
average you know because people have
achieved for a variety of different
reasons but on average men cheat because
they have this desire for sexual variety
and so you see this in
some clear cases like I to pick an older
example a Hugh Grant
um Elizabeth Hurley drop dead gorgeous
um model actress whatever and then he's
caught you know having sex with a
prostitute on the street and L.A like
what's going on he's not he's basically
trying to satisfy his desire for sex
writing people look at that and think
he's crazy because you know he's he's
with this gorgeous woman
um what is he doing but that's not
that's not that atypical and because
a primary reason for men
cheating is this desire for sexual
varieties it's not because
um she's better looking or higher in
made value it's just that she's
different
yeah yeah whereas for women
the primary motivation and not the
exclusive with primary motivation for
Affairs is because they're unhappy in
the relationship and they're looking to
either get out of a bad relationship or
an unsatisfactory relationship we're
looking to trade up in the mating market
so this is the the mate switching
hypothesis
is it true that of saying that men cheat
to stay and women cheat to leave then
um
well uh I would say the second is
definitely true women women cheat to
leave it now we're talking about like
about 70 to 80 percent of women this is
what studies of women who have had
affairs this is what their primary
motivation is is to get out of a
relationship or trade upwards or segue
back into the mating Market
um whereas men it's more like
um
Chris Rock had this quib of like men are
only as faithful as their opportunity
now that's an exaggeration
um
opportunities who don't act on them
um uh and it's true of men and women we
have opportunities and we we choose not
to act on them for a variety of reasons
it could be don't want to jeopardize the
marriage don't want to
um sacrifice my reputation in the eyes
of other people don't want to
um you know variety variety of reasons
why people choose not for religious
reasons or moral reasons or whatever
yeah let's hope that let's hope that uh
Integrity comes into that yeah yeah well
so that's a prime example was um uh and
you may be too young to remember this
but there was uh with uh President Jimmy
Carter uh he did an interview at Playboy
magazine a long time ago and he said he
had uh lust in his heart and that he had
committed many adultery many times in
his heart but as far as we know he never
acted on that
um but he confessed to what I think most
men have is they have this
ferocious desire for sexual variety
um and but some act on it when the
opportunities are there or the costs and
risks are low but many don't act on it
and his case as far as we know he never
acted on it and was always 100 percent
monogamously faithful to his wife
Rosalind I don't think it's the right
question to ask why do men want variety
I'm gonna ask instead what is it that uh
each gender
um
wants sex for and what does it mean to
them like what what is the sexual
psychology for a man versus a woman that
would lead to then of course why men
want variety
well that's a great question and um a
deep question because I mean it gets to
the heart of our our evolved sexual
psychology the reason that men have this
desire for sexual variety and it's
different from for men and women and
it's not that women have zero desire for
sexual variety but it's just that it's
low on average compared to men and and
there are so many examples of this so
just descriptively a man can walk down a
city block and pass half a dozen women
and have
thoughts about sex with that woman
within a span of two minutes
um and and I don't think women do now
women do become attracted to you know so
I hear you know even women who are in
stable relationships you know that uh
John uh Jon Hamm playing Don Draper you
know people become infatuated Don Draper
or uh or George Clooney
um or I don't know who I guess some
younger uh Ryan Gosling uh and and I can
think of a few yeah yeah we're historic
I don't know where Brad Pitt stands but
he used to be a sex simple and women
just like would croon over uh Brad Pitt
and perhaps have sexual fantasies about
Brad Pitt but
um but it's just like uh it's a it's
it's just still a massive difference uh
and this shows up this this sex and
friendship shows up in things like
a number of sexual thoughts per day
uh men how many more than women a number
of different people you have sexual
thoughts about men much higher than
women
um consumption of pornography about 80
of the pornography is consumed by men
then women and even the nature of the
pornography is very different you know
with men it's just there's no plot you
know there's like maid comes into the
hotel room
to clean up the room and within 10
seconds they're having sex uh you know
whereas women's pornography tends to be
more have some some plot some context
some romance
um and uh so it's even the nature of
men's and women's sexual fantasies are
very very different and this shows up
for example in I don't know if you've
ever read the stanika but like the the
romance novels like the the they should
be called bodice rippers you know where
you have on the covers it's like rugged
uh handsome dashing on some man who
happens to be a uh wildly successful
businessman or a prince or whatever he's
like off the charts and status
women desire him uh many women and but
he finds himself uncontrollably drawn to
this one woman sort of against his will
and then it's the modern day Fifty
Shades of Gray guy Christian Gray yes
yeah yeah exactly and um and you can bet
who's I mean who's it so these these
romance novels it's actually the largest
uh selling book category in the
publishing book publishing industry I
mean it's a multi-billion dollar
industry uh and um and it's a 95 of the
consumers of those books women are women
because men like to watch it and women
like to read about it yeah and and and
yeah it Taps it an entirely different I
mean it highlights the difference
between male and female sexual
psychology and and is it an imagination
thing
because like as like a low-level example
like you can say to a guy like oh what
should I wear and he might not be able
to kind of picture he's like I don't
know put something on and I'll tell you
like and a girl can go oh I don't know
like maybe like a cute little black
dress with you know like um some shoes
some like kind of boots you like what do
you have for like a girl might have this
vision of what something should look
like and a guy's like I don't know I
need to see it yeah yeah no I think
that's exactly right and
um all the studies point to exactly that
that with men the visual sense is
overwhelmingly the primary sense whereas
women it's uh it use a much wider range
of senses that are involved in their
sexual attraction you know so
touch sound
mood context setting up and then to your
point about these different um
imagining different dress scenarios I
mean women are just more uh they devote
more uh time attention and effort to
even thinking about those things and
have a most people don't know this they
have a much richer color vocabulary oh
um than men you know it's a man it's
like well there's there's like green and
red you know or and and for women they
have like six different words for green
the weather's teal and there's 14 and
there's you know it's mint yeah and then
yeah Christmas tree red versus emerald
green yeah and yeah yeah so um so even
women have this much richer
um sensory vocabulary for colors
uh so um so that's another that's
another really interesting sex
difference
um but but anyway so yeah so you get
these these fundamental sex differences
in our sexual psychology and then that
they play out in the real world
um and sometimes catastrophic ways
um and they also even
they can they play out within
relationships themselves because if you
figure so men have and this is again
this is maybe Politically Incorrect say
this but all the data show this is that
men have a higher sex drive on average
now there are women with very high sex
drives but men on average have a much
higher sex drive this is another Miss
because men's sex drive tends to be sort
of that
it's called 20 range 25 like 18 to 25
feels very high but then for a woman
it's like later 30s yeah but yeah for
when for when it Peaks right another
myth and like yeah which men and women
are miscalibrated yeah so so in terms of
sex drive ideally what you want you know
is a 35 year old woman with an 18 year
old guy who uh who's the pool boy
with with her 18 year old fertility
level or whatever if they are wanting to
move forward in that direction wait well
and that's another interesting thing is
that we found in our research that uh as
women's biological clock starts to take
down they their sex drive does go up and
they become more interested in
um you know acting interesting in in in
in in in correspondence to this internal
biological clock that is running out
essentially is that there's I think
that's actually a real life scenario
that plays out to
try and mate because perhaps a baseline
human nature is survival and survival
means procreation I would reverse that
and just say
the bottom line of evolution by
selection is
is reproductive success uh and so
survival is really only a means to that
very important means okay but but here's
another interesting thing we have to add
to the mix here and that is that
uh if you look at let's say a
um 20 year old woman in a natural
hunter-gatherer group she looks like a
40 year old woman in our society and so
and so I'm looking at you and if and if
someone just said like how old is um
uh how old are you I I wouldn't um I I
would say something like well maybe 30
32 or something like that
um and so part of that is that we live
in a modern environment where we're not
subjected to the you know the Hostile
forces of nature we're not
spending 12 hours a day in the sunlight
and you know uh you know tromping
through the woods and you know Gathering
berries and so forth and uh and so you
go to these hunter-gatherer societies
younger women do in fact look older and
in our society uh well older women look
quite young you know so
um and so that's another
um that's another interesting feature of
um of modern living which I think is is
great actually
everybody can stay younger looking
um for longer yeah
historically it's true what is the true
significance of cheating then because
the women are more emotional men tend to
be more you know about variety so so
yeah elaborate on the emotional side of
sex from each perspective a wonderful
question and again there are these
profound sex differences so let's take
uh Affairs for example so so in studies
of like
why do you have the affair or what would
be if you were to have an affair what
would be the reason so what what the
studies show is that 79 of women have a
fear is
um fall in love with their Affair
partner and become emotionally attached
to or emotionally involved with their
Affair partner for men the corresponding
number is about 30 percent uh so there's
this huge difference there
um and another indication is just even
people for people who don't have affairs
um sex and emotional connection are more
disjunctive in in men they're like more
separate things so like a study that was
done so uh they had this was done
originally on a college campus so they
had male and female
um Confederates as they were about this
doesn't mean people from the South but
it's just members of the experimental
team who were judged to be moderately
attractive walk up to members of the
opposite sex on a college campus and say
hi I've been noticing around campus
lately I find you very attracted would
you and they ask them one of three
questions would you go on a date with me
uh would you come back to my apartment
with me
would you have sex with me and they
simply recorded the percentage of
individuals who agreed to these three
different requests and of the women
approached about 50 agreed to go out on
a date with the guy six percent agreed
to go back to his apartment and zero
percent agreed to have sex of course um
women typically needed a little more
information about the guy of of the man
approached by the female Confederate
also about 50 percent agreed to go on a
date with her 69 percent agreed to go
back to her apartment and 75 would have
secular
how you're a man how do you answer yes
I'll just go back and have sex with you
let's just start there let's start there
it's a great question and well first of
all
um
uh one qualifier is that
um these Confederates were judged to be
moderately attractive but and equally
equally so
um for a man
um
sexual opportunities are very rare now
it may not seem that way in the modern
environment with Tinder and college
campus hookups and everything but
historically
um sexual opportunities were very rare
and even in the modern environment so
you go on
um Tinder for example and or OkCupid is
another dating site and there's studies
on a just a rate how attractive members
of the opposite sex are and Men rating
women that chose this normal
distribution where some women are very
attractive some of them are not so
attractive and they're you know as a
large number and kind of in the middle
or different range you ask women how
attractive men are
only about 20 percent make it up above
threshold
um and most women find most men just to
be below threshold on attractiveness and
so what that means is that men find
women on average more attractive than
women to find men
uh and so um and so these guys who are
approached by a woman this has probably
never happened to them in their life I
mean who of course it happens to uh
movie stars right because it's a very
small amount of men that are actually
getting the action yeah in the ranking
of it all because there's so many so
much criteria and so much judgment on a
a woman wants to mate with that or have
sex with him or connect with him so
there's just the pool is Tiny of the men
that are actually having sex with women
right right exactly and and it's gotten
tinier in the sense that
um
uh the men who are having sex let's say
the top 20 percent are having a lot of
it
a larger number of women
um and then in essence monopolizing us
leaving a larger and larger share of men
who are sexless and and that's why you
have these phenomena now the inso is an
extreme example
um but there's this pool of men who just
um uh can't find women
who are attracted to them and and this
is where this gets back to our earlier
discussion of the mating crisis where
um these guys are spending all their
time on uh on watching pornography on
social media uh playing video games uh
and so they're not interacting in real
life and how do you develop mating
skills you know skills of Attraction
skills of social interaction so you
actually have to meet people and
interact in real life and these guys are
not doing that and so there's has been a
rise of um anxiety and I think it's
actually anxiety of several different
sorts one is simply social anxiety where
men feel
awkward and when they especially when
they made an attractive woman they don't
know what to say what to talk about or
they you know and they get kind of
paralyzed with anxiety
uh and so they tend people tend to avoid
things that they're anxious about so
it's kind of is a vicious cycle
um and then fear second one is like a
subset is men fear rejection yeah and
which is um you know when they approach
a woman if they did and they fear being
shot down
um for good reason because they often
are shut down
um uh but the um the fear of rejection
has this paradoxical
ity where even though we're supposed to
live in a sexually egalitarian World 90
of women still expect the guy to make
the first move right another catch so
they're expecting the guy to make the
first move he's paralyzed with anxiety
and doesn't want to risk being shot down
uh and so they tend to avoid
interacting with women and so don't
develop the kinds of mating skills that
they need there's a whole
movement around men becoming more
vulnerable right men men
breaking this old pattern Paradigm of
women come home and clean and cook and
they go to work and they don't have to
be emotionally available or tell them a
damn thing and women are like we don't
want that anymore look it's not
connected I don't feel connected to you
I want you to show up for me in an
emotional way I want you to share with
me I want you to be more vulnerable I
want to hear about your feelings I want
to know about those things so now you're
talking about how a man is so scared to
be let down just rejected
um he doesn't want to deal with the the
anxiety or the pressures and so there
are so many opportunities to go into
um a solitary land of pornography and of
video games where they don't have to
interact they don't have to be they
don't have to be on they don't have to
be have the potential of getting
disappointed so it feels like actually
really part of this package of what
women are expecting men to be and their
men are just getting squeezed so hard
there's so much temptation to not have
to deal with it there's so many
opportunities to not have to deal with
it but it's actually making it worse for
men and they're becoming even more
unavailable because they don't even know
how to they don't even show up let alone
know how to talk to someone so it kind
of feels like part of that that
expectation level that I believe women
really do want now like we're just not
okay with you being emotionally
unavailable because one thing that women
traditionally can sense more than men is
energy and the true feelings of what's
going on and we're not okay with pushing
that down because we have options to
leave now so we we don't have to just
put up with disconnection we can go find
it yeah yeah and I think that's a great
set of points and
um but I would had a a Nuance to what
you just said and that is that women do
want guys who are emotionally available
not just to you know talk about their
emotions and feelings but also to be
genuinely interested in a woman's
emotional life as well okay but women
don't want a guy to be emotionally weak
you know so tell me what the difference
is then what's the how do you how do you
be how do you become an emotionally
vulnerable available man but not weak
well I think the week the week is
um falling apart under pressure or you
know as we we all experienced stresses
and strains and problems and Road bumps
and you know uh difficulties that we
have to cope with and so women want a
guy who can talk about those but not
fall apart under stress not curl up in a
ball in the bedroom and you know
um be beaten down by those you know
because in fact it's a sign of strength
you know and resilience to be able to
face the hurdles and problems that we
all face and make it through them and
figure out ways to solve them and get
past them
um and so um and so there is that issue
and I wonder I wonder and this is I mean
I haven't thought about this deeply but
your your set of points raises this
issue of how do men develop the ability
to be emotionally available and
communicative but not also show
emotional weakness because that's part
of what men are afraid of is you know
that they they don't want to appear weak
and then the question is what is weak
how would you define that yeah falling
apart not having the Psychological
Resources to be able to cope with the
challenges that everyone has to face in
their day-to-day life
okay so it feels to me like a man wants
to have the answers he wants to solve
problems but the thing about being
emotionally available and vulnerable is
that is that you don't have the answer
right right that's like the dichotomy of
it the the Paradox is that that the
vulnerability is like I don't know what
to do I'm lost I'm scared I'm sad I'm
whatever I feel I feel this negative
energy and I don't know how to fix it
which is the vulnerability that right
otherwise it's not a vulnerability it's
just a damn solution and you just go to
work like you wouldn't be sharing your
sadness if you knew exactly how to solve
the problem at work or to solve the
problem with your partner or with your
parents you wouldn't be on you wouldn't
be a wreck because you'd have the
solution and you'd just go do it yeah
yeah well and that's that's another
um sex difference right there is that
sometimes uh and I encounter this so
often in in couples is let's say the
woman let's say the woman wants to talk
about some difficulties she's having at
work you know with a co-worker or
something like that and the guys there
were like okay
you're here there's a straight line to
solving the problem B now let's let's uh
let's get dinner you know and the woman
doesn't necessarily want you know a
solution provided she wants the guy to
listen
to her describe what the nuances and
nature of the issues are and so there's
a but but I think guys are typically
more solution solution oriented and so
that and then that upsets the woman
because she wants the guy to listen to
her and listen to her nuances and
details and so forth you can see this in
conversations where
um and I've seen so many of these where
a woman's talking to another woman and
she says exactly they're talking about a
date that they went on date that one of
them went on the night before and so
they'll say well and then I said this
and he said that and I said this and he
said that and the other one will say
well now what was his facial expression
when he said that and so to go into the
the nuances in details in minutia of
their interaction and guys don't do that
I said like well how did the date go
um yeah well great uh we had sex it was
wonderful or I wanted to have sex she
didn't want to so I was frustrated so
it's it's a very different nature of um
male and female communication and and
create and create some problems in in
relationships because they're
communicating using very different
styles
yeah true but I will say as you were
describing the scenario of you know
there's a problem here's a solution I'm
like the guy like I am practical
rational you have a problem I want to
help you fix it so do you think that
there's also a problem with the kind of
woman that a successful female is
becoming by being more in charge
creating more of those rational salt you
know problem-solving techniques because
that's part of the nature of being
someone successful as you're usually
managing people you're usually directing
things you're in charge and so that then
trickles down into regular life and then
this sort of soft emotional oh what and
there's becomes this what happened today
oh do this and it's like maybe a man
really wants to be heard too or not like
is there a evolutionary sort of issue
with a female becoming more successful
or having more status more some more of
a working woman and the kind of woman
she's becoming not being what a man
really wants anymore well yeah I mean
that's a it's a great question and I
just I could speculate on that so so I I
don't know but my guess is from the
woman's point of view she wants a guy
who is also
good at and talented at those kinds of
decision-making abilities
and the women don't want a guy who's so
wishy-washy or
um doesn't know how to solve problems in
that in that directive way
um
and uh and so again we might get back to
that issue that you first brought up
Danica and there are early part of our
conversation which is that some of these
guys would be intimidated by women who
have those capabilities
so yes I've thought about that a lot and
the word that comes up when I when I go
into that space of being intimidated is
is really triggered
because
a man wants to feel powerful and this is
my understanding a man wants to feel
powerful he wants to feel
um
accomplished successful he wants to have
that mate status value of being higher
he wants that he wants that status
situation and so when
a man comes across a woman that
challenges that
he now has to see himself in that
scenario he now is actually getting that
mirror to you're not that and he he's
triggered because he hasn't reached
higher right you know challenged himself
enough or been lucky enough to be in the
right scenario to work for the right
person to climb the ladder to get the
salary to whatever it may be like I I
don't know is there
intimidated Feels Like An Unfinished
thought to me
yeah well I mean intimidated
um
in the sense that we talked about
earlier that
um
you know so so one
I mean in The Mating world so there's
there's mate selection there's made
attraction so uh there has to be mutual
mate selection mutual attraction but
there's also the problem of mate
retention uh so attracting someone is
not enough you know you have there's
mate retention as we know there's you
know high high breakup rates and uh with
guys they they want to be successful
mate retainers so they they don't want
to lose the one and so again if those
are indication indicators that she's
higher in mate value then statistically
she's going to be more likely to defect
and and leave the relationship uh and so
um and so that's why so and triggers
sexual jealousy by the way the lower
lower guys uh get triggered in terms of
sexual jealousy because they
realistically I think
um a praise that the woman has other
options and those other options might be
better than the option better than he is
and so again it's sort of a a realistic
um so you can say it's well it's due due
to the fragile male ego and he just
can't handle it
um but there's also a real component the
woman in reality is more likely to trade
up if she's with a guy like that
um
what about the this whole well let's
start with monogamy first because we've
already identified there are differences
in why a per why a man versus a woman
has sex and or cheats that there's
different different reasons for that so
is monogamy
completely natural I get asked this
question a lot of humans fundamentally
monogamous or are we fundamentally
religionous or promiscuous or
polyamorous right is marriage and mating
just to do with now like back in the old
days with uh keeping uh family land in
the land and the family or you know
riches or things like that or you know
the way I think about it is that we have
humans have an evolved menu of mating
strategies we don't just have one
long-term mating pair bonding and
attachment and I think that is part of
our mating strategy so if you go to our
closest primate relative who's the
chimpanzee with whom we share more than
98 of our DNA they don't have anything
resembling a long-term mating strategy
or a pair bonded mating strategy they
have the female comes into estrus female
chimp males mate with that female when
she's an asterisk she doesn't conceal it
she is you get the bright red genital
swellings and the over fact Factory cues
and then after she the estrus phase the
males are indifferent and they don't
interact much with the females anymore
uh and they don't um and they don't do
anything for The Offspring either so but
in humans you have these three things
that have co-evolved so you have one is
the evolution of long-term pair bonds
right and it's one of the mating
strategies
um I missed this menu two you have
relatively concealed ovulation so
compared to our chimps you men can't
tell when women are ovulating or not and
a lot of women can't tell now some women
are very sensitive to their bodies in
the modern environment you you can
get that information but three you have
the evolution of very high male parental
investment so in contrast to the male
chimps men do invest heavily in
Australia not always of course we have
deadbeat dads and guys who abandon their
families and all that but but compared
to all other primate species human males
men do invest uh sometimes a couple of
decades or more in their children they
protect them they feed them they
provision them they they put a shelter
over their heads Etc and so
um so so so we definitely have
long-term peer-bonded mating now that
doesn't necessarily mean monogamous
mating because we also have short-term
mating
we have a fair mating infidelity uh as I
as I mentioned uh we have serial mating
which is very common in our species so
you made with one person for a while
break up and then mate with another
person for a while break up and so worth
it that's a very common pattern
especially in the modern environment
um and then we have people who mix and
match and then a small minority of
people do polyamory
um and then historically there's also
been polygyny which is one man multiple
wives and that is
um against the law in this in in this
country but we have sometimes what you
might call effective polygyny you know
which is that top 20 of the men
sometimes engage in you know not
necessarily simultaneous wives but maybe
one long-term Aid after another after
another after so an extreme example
might be a Leonardo DiCaprio you know
who uh I'm sure you've seen those charts
where as he gets older the age of his
girlfriends stays the same
yeah lucky him
but he's he's an extreme example
um of that but I guess I mean you know I
mean some I mean there are other
examples
um I mean George Clooney I think sort of
did that for a while before he settled
down to what seems like a very happy
long-term uh marriage right so
what triggers that
what triggers settling down
to a happy long-term marriage
um I don't know that's a great question
um I know one guy and I don't know if
this is a general answer but his view is
he he's gonna mate
um as much as he can with different
women until his mate value uh kind of
plateaus and then he's gonna try to lock
in a high maintenance best you can find
woman so I I mean I don't I don't know I
mean I still have a I mean another
example of that in the Hollywood arena
is Warren baby you know who is a
notorious
um ladies man in his day but then met uh
Annette Benning and and settled down to
uh like I don't know 25 year 30-year
relationship with four kids and so forth
so probably good not to count on a guy
in his 20s um settling him down if he's
in that top 20 percent
oh that is the catch right there if he's
in the top 20 be careful of that explain
more because they have more options yeah
yeah yeah and like Chris Rock said
you're only as you're only as loyal as
your options yeah yeah an exaggeration
but there's some truth to it as well
um that
men who who can who have the opportunity
so and that's why you get um I mean
that's why it becomes problematic for
you know and I know I mean you've your
involvement in in racing and the Sports
World and you're familiar with all that
the the star
athletes
um and sports figures and rock stars I
mean they get they get a huge amount of
attention
um from women you know I mean oh yeah
the women definitely make it obvious for
the men I can't say that from the other
perspective being a female athlete the
men don't make it as obvious to women I
mean they can but I think it's much more
it's a much more dangerous situation for
a woman wanting one of those top 20 men
who especially are
Elite level
performers and celebrities to to imagine
that that's going to go well if you want
right and and the you know and the
problem is that it it doesn't stop so
even after
uh let's say um
Leonardo DiCaprio let's say he settles
down and gets married
you know does that mean that they're no
longer going to be any women interested
in him well I think the women will
continue to be interested in him
um so uh so and that that that you know
offers a set of temptations that you
know men are tempted to act on some do
and and but as we talked about earlier
some don't you know some don't want to
jeopardize their relationship and choose
choose not to act on those things so you
mentioned polyamory which is something
that I'm curious about
um because it does seem like the
relationship realm is
shifting
somehow it's shifting so polyamory is
one of those things that has become more
popular for sure so what
have you come across any studies data
um on polyamory working long term is or
is this merely a phase of trying to
figure out
because I feel like when there are
shifts in culture and patterns
the pendulum kind of can swing a bit and
like we're not always in a place that
we're going to stay but we're trying to
kind of find where we can settle but
it's not where we were so is polyamory
really a real option emerging in the
dating market and in relationships or is
this merely a phase on its way to
something yeah well that's a great
question and
um I don't know the final answer to that
I mean it's talked about more it's
written about more there's more open
polyamory than they're
um used to be I don't know if the actual
rates have gone up I guess it wouldn't
surprise me if they have historically
open relationships which is another term
for it there's all these different terms
so there's consensus
swinging historically they have tended
not to work one form of polyamory is you
have one primary partner but then you
have an open relationship where you
allow the other person to do X Y or Z at
The X Y or Z is typically worked out in
if it's consensual in an explicit kind
of way where you allow the other person
to do X and Y but not Z
and I know I've talked to many people
who are not many but I've talked to
let's say a dozen people who are
polyamorous who are friends students
Etc and I think that
um I think it's my intuition is that it
it can work but only for a very small
minority of people
I think most people are not cut out for
it and the reason is is that once you
introduce other people into the mix then
there's always the danger of
um let's say uh jettisoning the primary
partner and switching to one of your
parent Wars but there's also sexual
jealousy
and this is an emotion that we've we've
touched touched on earlier but I wrote a
whole book on sexual jealousy infidelity
and sexual jealousy and it's a very
powerful emotion and it comes online
when people fall in love and they form a
long-term peer-bonded attachment to the
other and so um and so this is one of
the they even call it the monster figure
in the polyamorous Community like how do
we cope with this jealousy because it's
not like it goes away
yeah and um you know so
now I think there's some people who are
really on the low side of jealousy and
so can somehow
deal with their partner having sex but I
know just like if you one example of a
couple that I know
who are they are each other's primary
polyamorous partner but they allow each
other to have sex with other people
um in her case she's bisexual and so
she's sometimes has sex with other women
sometimes other men
and when I talked to him he says um
that he really he doesn't bother him
very much if she has sex with another
woman but it really bothers him when she
has sex with another man
uh and then what she says is she she
says well it doesn't bother me if he has
sex with women but one time I saw him
walking down the street holding hands
with one of his paramours and that
really triggered her jealousy
yeah exactly that is the emotional
dimensions of
infidelity or involvement with other
people are much more bothersome to women
than to men in the sexual aspects of the
infidelity especially in this case
heterosexual aspects are much more
bothersome to men
and that's reflective of there's a large
literature on sex differences and the
triggers of jealousy
those who choose a polyamorous lifestyle
always have to struggle with
um with jealousy with sexual jealousy
and they find ways to get around it and
ways to minimize its negative impact on
their relationship but
um the short answer to your question is
there haven't been long-term studies to
see whether these things actually work
out over the long run and I'll mention
one other sex difference in that so I
know this one woman who was in a
polyamorous relationship
um and it was
and and this I think is often the case
that it's the guy who is wants to drag
the woman into Napoleon's relationship
for the desire for sexual variety I
think is the motive behind it and women
sometimes go along with that
because they they want to keep the guy
that is his mate retention tactic even
though you know they're willing to go
along even though it's not their
preferred option they're afraid of
losing him so they go along with it so
there's a there's an on average sex
difference in that
um but this woman that I'm thinking
about she was you know visited she was
extolling all the virtues of polyamory
or whatever uh and then um
then she got divorced from her primary
partner they were married and
subsequently she got remarried uh and
had a kid and it's no longer at all from
that moment of the divorce is no longer
involved in the polyamorous Community
right so
my guess is that that's that's more
typical but we don't really know sir
there haven't been in a good long-term
studies of polyamorous it requires them
to be honest too it requires people to
be open to talking about it honest about
their situation and it's also a much
more new pattern in society that is
available that is
you know something people are sharing
more about like what's the reason for
someone to have enough discipline to
choose someone and stay with them and
stay monogamous and loyal part of it
might be that people have to adjust
their mate preferences so
um so the things that people select on
are not necessarily the things that lead
to long-term stable happy relationships
so so the other side of it just to add a
a wrinkle to your question is that there
are people who do stay married and do
stay monogamous but they live lives of
uh the proverbial quiet lots of quiet
desperation where they're and they feel
unhappy or unfulfilled or unsatisfied
but it's not bad enough for them to
leave the relationship and and you know
go out back out in the making Market
dangerous place to be for it to me not
bad enough but also not good enough yes
yeah and I think there's there's a chunk
of people who fall in that category uh
uh and so they they stick it out even
though it's you know and then they get
to the end of life yeah they were
monogamous they were loyal but I didn't
necessarily lead a very fulfilling
um life in the in that respect but in
terms of selecting like one of the one
of the most important predictors of
um marital happiness to studies of
married couples is emotional stability
and this circles back to another
theme that we talked about earlier
and
um one way to think about emotional
stability is
um I mean there are other words for
moodiness or emotional labability or
emotional reactiveness uh or whatever
but
um the demand it's a very important
personality to mention and one way to
think about it is that
we all experience
challenges and problems and stress and
and what happens with emotionally
unstable people is they get their
equilibrium gets knocked out of whack
and it takes them a long time to return
to that stable psychological equilibrium
whereas emotionally stable people they
might get upset or they make you angry
or whatever but then they return to
Baseline much more quickly
and so that's one key Hallmark of that
and what I found so I've studied
newlywed couples and married couples and
looked at well what predicts conflict in
relationships and what predicts you know
marital satisfaction and whether they're
going to stay together over the long
term and this is one of the most
important personality herb was that
predicts that so if you're if you're
with someone who's emotionally unstable
um then you're in for all kinds of
problems in conflict and and uh and
they're just a net drain they what I saw
a high relationship load you know it's
um so we have things like um mutation
load uh parasite load
um you know different different types of
loads and there's a concept that I've
turned relationship load where someone
just is
you know it's costly to deal with this
person uh because they're always upset
they're always you know raising problems
they're just like uh uh you know and
that takes time and attention and effort
away from other life tasks that people
need to do but anyway uh nobody very few
people prioritize this personality
Dimension when they select mates they
they go on or is this person attractive
you know are they uh do they have hot
status are they respected by their peers
uh maybe in in long-term parabundum
mating are they a kind person or a
generous person you know do they have a
you know a good Suite of personality
characteristics but emotional
instability is not something you can
assess accurately
um very quickly
and so that's why I tell people you know
if you're getting serious about someone
go on vacation to a foreign country
where neither of you speak the language
and where you have to
you know face stresses and strains and
get by in different ways and I'm not
talking about going to a resort where
everything is included and everyone does
everything for you I'm talking about
like come on that's the only way I do it
well uh but but that's not the way to
find out what the personality
characteristics of your partner are and
and I think that that's it's just one
way to very quickly fast-track getting
an accurate assay of these personality
characteristics
um and so um but but very few people
place a priority on that in their mate
selection and so I think what one way to
think about it is we need to prioritize
things if you want a long-term stable
happy monogamous relationship you need
to prioritize things that are actually
going to lead to that
um and the things that we prioritize
don't necessarily lead to that they may
lead to other things
um excitement you know you marry someone
who's um
high in status and gets invited to all
the celebrity events or whatever it
might be the very exciting life but it
might be a very short-lived life
or in terms of the relationship well
what's let me ask you what what's the
longest relationship you've had
um
not almost 10 years
10 years actually this is how it's gone
10 years almost five years two and a
half years one year two months okay wow
wow okay what does that say I don't know
yeah I I laugh and say that the next one
is totally the one or it's
a week you know yeah well that's that's
a very interesting pattern
um well so what what do you think
accounts for the shift in the longevity
of your relationships I think it's
putting up with less knowing myself
better having more self-awareness and
not being willing to
uh deal with not being happy always
having options I've always had options
you know like you talked about in the
beginning that some some women
especially more in the past when there
was less Financial stability upon both
parties you know I've said from the
beginning I'm not stuck I don't have
children with anyone I don't I can I
there's multiple houses I'm not stuck if
I'm not happy I just I deserve to be
happy to I don't have to stay okay so so
do you think that there has been
anything in your pattern of mate
selection
that has resulted in these shorter time
periods or is it are you selecting for
the same qualities but they you're just
less willing to put up with the that's a
good question I I think that
um yes is true to the second part where
you said I'm less willing to put up with
things but I also think and maybe you've
kind of researched around this too but I
also think that we we date with a
pattern
and so this usually is derived from our
from our familial situation where
in my scenario I learned that you know I
was attracting guys that were like my
dad because the original wound of trauma
and relationally came from my dad so we
moved forward in life and we try and
write the original wrong with each
relationship but we never can because
we're picking a pattern that's just a
pattern and it becomes less and less
tolerable to us because we like as a as
as a being we become more and more aware
of it and we're trying to get to the
point where we don't now seek that
pattern anymore and that's not a wound
to heal it is healed or it is
acknowledged and learning that I acted
like my mom which was ultimately the
most important piece of the puzzle not
the dad Dynamic but actually that I
acted like my mom that then allowed me
to be in these relationships was what
gave me more keys to be able to go okay
I can't do that like for me it was being
emotionally unavailable for me which
meant the way that I treated myself was
I was emotionally not taking my care of
myself and completely ignoring my
emotions myself like I was treating
myself the same way my mom was treating
me and that was the same way I'm sure
her mom was treating her and you know
because it's a pattern and so now my
work is to go I am not going to
emotionally abandon myself minor child
whatever you want to call it because it
makes me unhappy and I want to be happy
so I have to treat myself with emotional
presence and availability so how so how
do that how would that translate into
your made selections so have you have
you altered the qualities that you look
for in a potential mate it created
boundaries so you know those boundaries
get delayed down pretty quickly
and pretty solidly like I'm not going to
put up with this this isn't going to
work for me as opposed to in the past
just moving through life and just going
not stating what I needed didn't even
know what I needed and was way too
afraid to say what I needed because it
might not fit and then they might go so
codependency being a part of that too so
um I wonder how much of sort of the The
Mating mating world is derived not only
from sort of the status situation that
we've talked about a lot but also trauma
yeah well and
so but it sounds like given that
emotional availability and
expressiveness is very important to your
happiness how do you identify those that
quality or that set of qualities in a
potential mate uh you go through some
trials and you go through some
challenges and also their ability to
share and ultimately share things that
are Unbecoming yeah I think that's a
good indicator of when someone is
emotionally available is that they they
they want your help they re they ask for
assistance in some way they they share
that they don't have the answer as well
as
um that they're willing to share things
vulnerably that are not so becoming but
it's honest and part of their story yeah
well and that's a sign of psychological
strength someone who's willing to do
that
invulnerable and chair
um
weaknesses if you will yeah yeah so I
can't say I have all the answers I'm not
I'm by no means uh but it's not like I'm
like yeah and all of a sudden I figured
it out and I've been married for 10
years super happy uh marriage do you
think that this is an institution that
is necessary that is
um going to remain or be changed
different and have a different opinion
of
pretty substantial decline in marriage
rates over the last even the last 10
years or so I'm inclined to
think that it will will remain
um it maybe not as um
uh at high as high levels or as
frequently or with as large a share of
the population as has been true
historically but I think that what
marriage is is part of that um pair
bonding long-term mating strategy Where
You Are
um sending a signal of public commitment
that's what marriage has always been a
public commitment you were it's it's
less for you than telling the the social
world that you are in this committed
relationship with this person
um and uh and I think that public
commitment is is an essential part of of
marriage you know so I mean yeah you can
have a happy long-term mateship that no
one knows about or you know that you
don't public broadcast or we're just
we're just dating
um but um I think that making that
public commitment
helps people to want to work through
some of the trials and tribulations that
all relationships go through I mean you
you know and so I think it's um I think
it's here to stay uh I think that it
used to be the expectation was that
everybody will get find someone and get
married and live happily ever after or
miserably Ever After as the case may be
and I think that you know there are
there are more different Lifestyles uh
that are available and permissible and
so it used to be there's a huge stigma
associated with getting divorced for
example yeah um and now there isn't you
know I mean everybody's everybody's got
married not divorced and so um so but I
think it's it's here to stay but but not
for as large a share of the population
perhaps due to the availability of
alternative lifestyles
okay well what about the idea that
um or the potential that
marriage
which implies something legal what if it
becomes commitment ceremonies of public
awareness right like so you go get
married essentially you do all the same
things but it's just not a legal thing
like it's a ceremony there's Rings
there's the sign that you're with you
know it's sort of like the the Eternal
marker that you were taking there's
people there there's there's pictures
there's the whole thing it's just like
marriage but it's not legal because that
seems like you know
like you know there's that sort of
saying like
can't believe that you know we take this
beautiful relationship and then get the
go you know get get get the legal team
involved like is that really necessary
yeah yeah I don't think it is necessary
as long as it has that kind of public
signal interesting
uh yeah I don't like that I'm not a big
fan of the government getting uh
involved in personal relationships uh
myself so um so but I think the public
aspect of the commitment is what's
critical
interesting yeah I I I
um I like that I think that makes sense
what ends up leading to like with the
study of evolutionary psychology you're
essentially you know you're looking at
these patterns of history and how they
evolve and I'm sure I'm not articulating
at all perfectly for like the correct
definition exactly but what I'm really
just wondering is
how does it change
like how what is it that creates a shift
in culture and in society that is then
something that you go and look back on
time and go it changed like this like
what is it that creates those those
shifts in culture
well
that's that's a that's a that's a huge
question oh shoot
um I mean that we could spend at least
an hour talking about that but I think
the way that I think about it is that we
have this evolved psychology which is
just like we have an evolved set of mate
food preferences you know this we we all
have taste preferences for uh sugar fat
salt and protein and in the modern
environment we're just kind of
activating our taste preferences
um but the modern world is so
fundamentally different and is changing
at an increasingly accelerating rate
especially in the mating Arena where 10
years ago you had a little bit of online
dating now
everybody's doing online dating or or
it's gotten totally destigmatized is
that everybody I know one uh student of
mine she said she's literally never been
on a date with anyone that she hasn't
first met online and this is to me this
is crazy because you know I mean you
want to meet people in real life uh but
but so uh the dramatic shift toward
online dating I think is creating a
massive cultural shift
um the availability of online
pornography and the consumption of
online pornography has created a massive
shift I think
um social media and the
um design of social media to capture our
attention and absorb our attention and
and uh all these things are
changing so we're living with this um
evolved ancient psychology that evolved
for a world that we no longer live in
and so there's a mismatch or Suite of
mismatches between the circumstances in
which we evolved and the current
environment which we live
uh and so I think some of these things
are are having detrimental impacts like
the the huge proliferation of just
social media for example
um there's some evidence at least that
it's resulted in increases in depression
and anxiety
um
uh you know in part because we evolved
in social groups where social
relationships are critical to our
survival have always been proven to our
survival but also to our happiness and
sense of well-being
and now people have you know a thousand
Facebook friends who they've never met
but they don't have any real
relationships you know where they feel
someone is deeply involved in their
welfare I think that's actually what's
characteristic of a good long-term
mateship is someone who is deeply
involved in your welfare and you're
deeply involved in their welfare and we
don't have that as much nowadays with so
much superficial social interaction that
occurs through messaging and online
stuff and less and less real life
interaction and real life relationships
so I think that
recognizing
uh some of these mismatches is critical
to solving some of the problems we're
facing with the current changes in in
our environment in cultural evolution
I love that to care about each other
like it's um just really feels like a a
macro solution to so many things right
now yeah
another phrase that I use is deep
engagement you know you want to have
deep engagement with another person and
that's how you know who your true
friends are as well as who a true mate
is for you and in the modern environment
we have like a million superficial
quote friends but a lack of deep
engagement so what would signify that
deep engagement could you give us all
just a couple couple bullet points of
what what that looks like so that we can
try and go achieve that well
that's also a complicated question but
one thing is
um what I call uh and this is in the
terms of evolutionary psychology and
it's kind of a clunky phrase but an
altruistic welfare trade-off ratio and
what welfare trade-off ratio is is you
know say we're in a relationship do I
how much value do I place on my welfare
relative to your welfare and so a
successful relationship is one where
um I place a tremendous value on your
welfare and you also place a tremendous
value on my welfare so what that means
is I'm making sacrifices so instead of
let's say I don't know
um going to the bar to have drinks with
my buddy you need to talk through a
problem or whatever that I'm willing to
sacrifice going to the bar and having
drinks with my buddies because you need
me now and someone you are willing to
make personal sacrifices at times for
for my welfare and so I think that that
that an altruistic an altruistically
skewed welfare trade-off ratio is one of
the keys to that as opposed to a
selfishly skewed welfare trade-off ratio
where someone says no I have my needs my
wants or whatever and so I'm just going
to do whatever I want and you know who
cares about the effect on you if it
makes you unhappy then just get over it
that's not going to work
that's my two cents on on that question
perfect I'm sure thank you for deducing
it down to something that we can grab
onto in this conversation and hopefully
someday we have another conversation
maybe when this book comes out I'm so
excited you're writing with Chris Chris
is obviously super fascinating with
evolutionary psychology as well he's um
super smart guy he's great with
Statistics and loves to dive into the
science and the uh you know all the
research on things so you guys will be a
great team on that yeah I think so it's
it's kind of a
we have very complementary skills you
know more of the basic scientists who's
studied human mating for years and years
and years and he is uh super smart and
also
um well good with Statistics but he's
also a very good communicator
um he can take findings and studies and
communicate them in a succinct and
Powerful way that people get the the
message and so uh so I have a lot of
respect for him and become friends with
him he lives here in Austin yeah
everybody you live in Austin yeah
everybody lives in Austin
so well it's a good place to live well
thank you so much for this time and all
of this information I look forward to
exploring in the future how we've
evolved and more solutions yes okay
terrific and best of luck between now
and F1 the best of luck and and your
amazing life thank you very much okay
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button